[music playing]
GRADY POWELL: Well, gentlemen,
congratulations to the two
of you.
You have beat out
the competition
in the first and second round
of our Arctic Forge Challenge,
which means you're
both one step closer
to check for $10,000
and the title of "Forged
in Fire" Champion.
Now, guys, in this final
round of competition,
we're going to send you
back to your home forges
to build yet another iconic
weapon from the ice cold North.
And that weapon is the
Northern Long Seax.
DAVID BAKER: The Northern Long
Seax is a single-edged blade
widely used by Vikings and
northern European tribes
during the Middle Ages.
Its razor-sharp edge and pointed
tip were useful in slashing
as well as for thrusting,
allowing the user to deliver
heavy blows and stabs to
finish off an opponent
in close quarter combat.
Although used as
a deadly weapon,
the Vikings would also
use the Seax to hack
tree branches and skin animals.
Today, the versatile
blade can be
seen in Netflix historical
drama series "The Last Kingdom."
Now, guys, you only have four
days to build these blades,
and when you come back, we
want to see two Seaxes that are
worth at least $10,000 apiece.
Because that's what one
of them will win you.
Good luck, guys.
We'll see in four days.
Good luck.
Yeah.
DEVON CHATTERLEY:
I'm Devon Chatterley.
I'm 29 years old.
I am an active
National Guardsman,
and I am a part-time bladesmith.
I need to come in here
gung ho-- full focus.
I'm ready to become the next
"Forged in Fire" Champion
and join the other
winners before me.
Oh my gosh!
I noticed that it concaved
going up to the drop point,
so I'm going to
start drawing out
that metal wide as possible.
Because I need this
to make parameters.
There we go.
That's the one I
was looking for!
I couldn't be more proud.
Let's get started on the handle.
I'm going to cut
up some aluminum
bar stock for the pommel.
It threads.
Whoo!
All right.
Now it's even more snug.
Today I'm just going to
focus on the little details.
I know my handle's a
bit plain and bland,
but at least it'll be shiny.
I just want to make sure
this weapon will perform,
so at the end of this
day, I will be testing
it out as much as I can.
OK, here we go.
[laughter]
Sliced right through.
I got my blade done!
I'm very happy with it.
It cuts.
It kills.
It's pretty much perfect.
My name is Clay Wolf.
I build houses for a living,
and I'm a part time bladesmith.
I got into smithing by
watching the competition.
So I bought a forge, and then
I started doing my own at home
competitions with myself.
I set a three hour
alarm, and I make
random parameters for myself.
And I go at it.
Those look like they're
setting really well.
There we go.
So I decided to put some
detail on my spine--
make it stand out a little bit.
I'm just working on my handle.
And as I'm looking at it, I
notice it has a twist to it.
I cannot turn
something like that.
I'm going to stick
it in the forge
and try to hammer this straight.
There's a slight warp,
but that'll have to do.
Well, we got the forge
lit, so we might as well
try to heat treat this thing.
Hard.
Good quench, good quench.
This wood I'm using is walnut,
and what's special about this
is this tree grew
on my family farm
and was cut down on
our family saw mill.
And it looks amazing.
I couldn't be happier.
I have an edge on
this, but I really
want to see how sharp it is.
So I need to test this blade.
I really hope that this is going
to cut through these bottles
with ease.
I hope my blade's sharp enough,
but we're going to find out.
This blade just cut right
through the water bottles
with ease.
They're clean cuts.
I couldn't be happier.
I feel confident sending
this back to the forge.
I can't wait to see it tested.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, bladesmiths.
Welcome to the KEAL test.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapons will do,
I will take your weapon and
deliver some lethal blows
on this pig carcass.
Clay, are you ready to play?
Yes, sir.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, let's do this.
Whoa!
[music playing]
All right, let's talk about
your Northern Long Seax here.
You have a forward heavy blade.
With that forward weight, it
really allows for deeper chops.
The edges are sharp.
They cut deep.
And overall, sir, your weapon--
it'll KEAL.
That's all I wanted to hear.
All right, dapper Devon.
You're up next.
Are you ready, sir?
I'm pumped.
Let's do this.
Nice.
Thanks, man.
[music playing]
All right, Devon.
Let's talk about
your weapon here.
The blade you have
here is nicely
balanced-- that when
I cut, the weapon
does not do the work for me.
I do the work with every slash.
As you can see, I cut it down
twice all the way through.
Overall, sir, your Northern
Long Seax will KEAL.
Thank you, sir.
J. NEILSON: Bladesmiths,
welcome to our strength test.
Fittingly for this
Arctic Challenge,
we're going to do
the ice block chop.
It really tests the edge
holding and overall construct
of your knives, and
it's a lot of fun, too.
Clay, you're first.
You ready to go?
Give her hell.
[grunting]
[music playing]
All right, Clay, I've got a
little bit of an issue here.
Your grain's not that bad.
I mean, it could be finer,
but it's not that bad.
But every time I hit, that
blade vibrated like crazy.
And it just traveled down.
So it started to
bend, and then all
that vibration and everything--
it just finally came loose.
I hate to see a nice
Damascus pattern
like this have something
happen to it like that,
but, hey, it was
a good fight, man.
GRADY POWELL: We
hate to see it, Clay.
Unfortunately, your blade
did succumb to this test.
But you're not out
of the fight yet.
Devon, you have to survive
six blows in the same test
to claim the title and
the check for $10,000.
You ready?
Let's do it.
[grunting]
Devon, congratulations, man.
Thank you.
GRADY POWELL: Clay--
difficult test.
And I want to say, thank you
so much for your hard work.
But unfortunately, due to
the catastrophic failure,
we couldn't continue
the testing.
So unfortunately, man, your time
here in the forge has ended,
and I have to ask you
to please step out.
Thank you.
Well, Devon,
congratulations, man.
You are today's
Arctic Forge Champion.
You absolutely deserve it.
That is a brutal test,
and you crushed it.
[clapping]
Thank you.
I can't believe
this just happened.
I am the "Forged
in Fire" Champion!
And I'm just thanking all the
support I've had from my wife.
My first plan is to
take my wife to Miami.
We're going to get out
of this cold weather
and go sit on the beach
for at least four days
and just relax in the sunlight.
I'm very excited.